At the Göbsi peak near Gonten in Switzerlandand 1200 meters above sea level, two artists
have set up a bed.
The walls and roof are absent.
The Hotel with no stars was dreamt up by twin brothers Frank and Patrick Riklin.
“The interesting thing about the hotel is
that many people don't know what it is.
Is it art, tourism or innovation?
The most exciting thing about it is that we
make people a bit uncertain.”
Forget wallpaper, the scenery around this bed is the draw for visitors from all over the world.
We designed this bed, built it and opened
up shop - and it's been "no vacanies" ever since.
“Turning the tables is part of the gag ... zero stars, doesn't mean bare-bones basics.
Instead, it's about experiencing a whole new kind of luxury.”
Farmer Köbi Dietrich didn't have much to
do with art -- until now.
Now he works as a consierge and butler.
“At first I didn't think this would involve
me so much, but I'm pleased to be part of
this bed idea.”
After milking the cows every evening, the
alm farmer dresses up for art.
“The idea was to figure out how to shape
the concept -- which is art, of course -- and  bring it to life so the players, the people who live around this artwork, become part of it.
Without him, it would be far too conventional.
He jumps and hops or “slips is right.
Slips right into this artwork.
Speaking as an artist, the project is like
a painting, but it's alive.”
A lonely farmer, who spends the summer on the mountain apasture with only his wife,
children and cows for company is enjoying the constant flow of visitors.
“There've been two marriage proposals.
One came in a helicopter.
That gave me goosebumps.
It was really touching, and then agreed to
marry him.
I've never been able to experience so closely what I see here now."
A night at the hotel costs about 270 euros, alpine views and breakfast included.
The new guests have arrived.
The two friends from Geneva were able to step in when a vacancy opened at the last minute.
They're the first guests to meet the artists
in person.
“I think it is the best idea in the world.
It is amazing.”
The two feel at home right away.
Raphael Tamman's drone hovers above them to immortalize their "mountain high."
“It's brilliant.
I was the one who said we should come here.
And now we've got this sunset to look at.”
“Who else is gone asleep like this, in the
middle of the most beautiful mountains of  the world, with a sunset like that.”
"I can't even realize yet.
I think I need a bit of time.
It's unreal, it's unreal.”
Entertainment is analogue and consists of watching the weather, telling jokes or listening
to music.
It's an artistic critique of the digitization
craze.
The guests are the stars at this hotel.
“When you see how people react, how they move around in this artwork and get excited
about it, then we get enthusiastic ourselves.
We can see that our concept is alive.”
Rain in the morning forced the guests to retreat to farmer Dietrich's mountain hut.
The farm's eggs, milk and ham are on the breakfast menu.
All the food is locally sourced.
"It's a dream and than you wake up in the
morning and it's not a dream.”
“It was quite an experience.
I actually slept amazingly well, the bed was super comfortable.
So it was very nice.
There was a bit of mosquitos, but it's fine.
You get used to it."
The artists have turned down commercial offers for their concept - including one bid worth
millions.
They say they want to leave the hotel's future open.